Now new data out this morning from the
office for National statistics has
revealed how the cost of living crisis
is impacting businesses it shows the
number of company insolvencies has
reached its highest levels since the
aftermath of the financial crash in
2009. well I'm joined now by the
business Expert Gemma Godfrey to break
it all down for us hello again to you
Gemma now it's not sounding great
already for so many businesses
insolvencies liquidations what are we
talking about here and just how
significant is it well the breaking news
was talking about insolvent companies
which are companies that can't afford to
pay back the money they owe but we also
have companies are liquidating which are
already selling off their assets to be
able to pay back these debts that they
owe and if we look at this chart which
actually combines those two numbers
what we can see there is if you go all
the way over there is actually there are
more companies that are shutting down
their operations than we saw at the peak
of the financial crisis this is how
serious it is we actually saw it
basically during covid when the
government came out and gave companies a
bit of financial support it temporarily
went down but we're seeing it all feed
through now and if we look at what's
causing that
um it's unsurprising that it's been
caused by energy bills so what this
shows is that businesses that are still
operating are expecting that when they
go to fix their energy costs again
they're going to be seeing an increase
in their electricity bills by either two
times four times and this is 50 of
companies and another quarter of
companies think they're going to see a
four-fold increase in their energy costs
which is which means that there's likely
to be more companies going insolvent and
bankrupt which means that we could
potentially see job losses and in how
it's going to impact us immediately if
we look at the red areas here is that
this shows us that over half of the
companies actually haven't yet passed on
the cost to Consumers and in particular
we're going to feel feel this is in arts
and entertainment so things like cinema
tickets will be going up in price or
theater tickets as well and that leads
me on to my next question which is how
is this going to impact consumers prices
have increased already and is this going
to get a whole lot worse absolutely and
the challenges that we've seen certain
price increases for consumers but a lot
of businesses haven't wanted to pass on
prices because if we look at the next
chart what this shows us is the
difference between the money we're
spending and the value we're getting so
the red line shows us the money we're
spending the Blue Line shows the amount
that we're buying for that amount that
we're spending and what you can see is
for the first time since since covert
since the pandemic we're now spending
more money and getting less value for it
and what's most concerned if you look at
the blue line is it's starting to dip
down into negative territory below the
100 line which means that we're actually
starting to buy less and that will
obviously feedback into companies you
know selling less Goods which will mean
that more of them will be going
insolvent and where we are actually
holding back on where we're spending is
we're still spending on essential Goods
which is the Blue Area there but we're
really delaying a lot of unnecessary
spend so you break your phone you're not
necessarily going to go out and replace
it or buying new clothes but the concern
is once you've delayed as much as you
can people might fall into debt in order
to pay for their essential goods and
we're already hearing about that Gemma
for now thank you